sort of crisp and effici is that first
quarter win the rest away it's a whole
different story where where you most
disappointed in sort of where the bottom
to um well that first nine minutes was
um a work of art just you know on both
sides of the basketball um with our
blitzes getting the B of Lucas's hands
and then offensively just you know way
we played um the way we attacked and so
that was good to see and then you know
we just got to get used to you know that
second unit with our with our small
lineup you know um just defensively what
we got to do um to be better and like I
said our guys they're competing just you
know we're just not big enough I think
you know so um just trying to find ways
to tweak that that lineup um the second
unit when we come in and go small um cuz
defensively we're not that good so um
that's up to me to get that done like I
said not taking away from the guys that
competing playing hard just you know
when it's just a bigger difference of
you know height advantages and stuff
like that um it's it's it's tough so we
just got to you know go back to the
drawing board but you know our young
young guys came at the end they competed
as well I like what they did um they had
to bring Luca back at the end of the
game but we had some good spurts you
know and so you know I thought James in
that first quarter probably the most
comfortable he's been since he's been
here I thought um Kawai you know same
way just the way he attacked and um the
speed and Pace that he played at in that
first in that first quarter so um just
got to keep going to the like I said
just keep staying together keep working
you know keep competing and um you know
it'll turn for us but I did like some
things but some things we got to get
better at you know the the best lineup
is it's clearly something you have to
keep working on but why do you think it
was such a struggle for the stars I mean
James didn't score in the first quarter
Paul was scor for half time the first
time it's ever happened since he joined
Clippers why do you think it was so hard
half that first qu get the starters kind
of back into that Rhythm um I'm not sure
I got to watch it you know to see you
know but like I said I think you know
the lineups changed little things were
different you know so um but we we got
to continue to play through the game you
know so um just look I got to go back
can look at it like you said in that
second quarter and just how we continue
to keep our starters you know playing
the same way they did to start the game
so um I'll definitely do that the way
you switched up the rotations bring Ross
back with that second unit are you
saying that you'd go back to that you
want to see more of that to give it
another try or is that sort of no I like
that yeah I like I mean I just didn't
like us defensively you know and just
understand what we want to run
offensively cuz you know not having a
big in the game that can roll and kind
of you know put pressure on the rim is a
little different for us you know so iide
did like you know Russ and PG coming
back with that second unit you know
which would be good for us and kind of
let Kawai and James and that you know
kind of finish the first quarter once
they get their legs and they able to
play a whole first quarter I think it'll
be good for us you mentioned James
obviously came out first quarter in a
rhythm why was he not able to get in
flow after that and how do you as you're
bring in this guy who's obviously you
know been a big time player throughout
his career how do you get him to be able
to kind of consistently be in the Flor
um I think for me just making sure we we
keep a big on the floor at all times
with James as much as possible because
the way he runs pick and rolls and he
can get down here and make every play um
whether it's to the big whether it's for
himself or whether it's for his
teammates and so I think the small
lineup doesn't really fit him well right
now you know until he gets you know in
better shape and game shape so I think
he a five on the floor with him as much
as possible really be good for us then
obviously you s those guys for score be
what it was given that your your team
was undergoing such a significant change
during the season was there any thought
to you know mixing a match and trying to
get some of those you know those guys
some some time together some minutes
together um it was a thought but I just
figured let them get their rest we have
a big game Sunday at 12:30 which we
haven't been particularly great at over
the last four years and so um my
thinking was just you know let's get out
of the game healthy um and get ready for
a 12:30 game on Sunday you mentioned
want to keep games with a big as much as
possible made you want to go the second
half and start with T man instead of zoo
there um I just thought you know for us
to be able to switch and try to Fire and
try to be faster um we putting zoo in
some tough positions having to Blitz you
know every time running out the hole and
having to scramble around so I just
thought you know starting small being
able to switch and fire I'm going be
good for us it didn't work but you know
got to try something when you're down 30
at halftime
obviously you guys know this is going to
be process it takes time you said that
over and over what are other mistakes
you've seen this last week that you
thinking we should be ahead of that we
should be better than that yeah I think
defensively you know I think our blitzes
our fires just our rotations um we
should be ahead of the curve on that we
have to be better um just understanding
what we're trying to take away what
we're trying to do um we have special
players like Kyrie and Luca and trying
to get the ball out of their hands just
knowing our rotations and then have an
impact on those double teams not not let
Luca just look us over jump p and skip
it all across the floor you know so just
put more heat on him and just making
sure our rotations are
better the first 9 minutes for work of
hard what's that me the last 30
minutes what's what's the worst that you
can
be but I'm tell you it's going to be
good Andrew that's all right we'll be
all right they better take advantage of
it now we'll be all
right